(SINGING)
[PLAYS NOTES ON VIOLIN]
Yes!
[MUSIC - MARIAH CAREY,
"FANTASY"] Oh,
when you walk by every night--
I love creating music.
Having melodies run through
me is an incredible feeling.
I just hear what I
hear, and I sing it.
In the beginning,
in my first album,
I didn't know that
I was producing.
Mind you, like, I'm a
teenage girl at this point,
and I'm sitting there
with grown men going,
can you raise the strings here?
I want to do just an
acappella moment right here,
and then we'll bring
the beat back in.
That is production.
There's power in that,
and nobody really
wanted me to feel powerful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When we talk about the
power of your voice,
there can be power in anything
from a whisper to a scream,
literally.
[MUSIC - MARIAH CAREY, BRANDY,
"THE ROOF"]
It wasn't raining yet--
--yet--
--but it was definitely--
Then there's the power
of self-expression,
and I want to do
this because this is
what I'm feeling in my heart.
You said (SINGING) ba,
da, da, da, da, bop.
Yeah.
[PLAYS SAME SEQUENCE ON VIOLIN]
Yeah!
[LAUGHS]
As a singer, as a
songwriter, I've
chosen to be very, very specific
and real about certain things.
Keeping things general,
but still trying
to reveal a specific emotion
that I was feeling in
hopes that other people
could relate to it.
That stuff really
matters to somebody
that listens to lyrics.
Music saved my life
in many, many ways.
If I can do the same for other
people, then that's everything.
I'm Mariah Carey, and
this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[KISS]
[YAWN-HOWLS]
[LAUGHS] Please tell
me you got that.